[Music]
this morning in our Saturday session a
return visit from Lilly and Madeline the
sisters from Indianapolis got their
start singing cover songs and posting
them online that caught the interest of
a music producer and started their
recording and performing career
including their TV debut on this show
five years ago their third album
Canterbury girls came out yesterday
they'll perform from it in a moment but
first I spoke with the sisters at Rough
Trade records in Brooklyn New York
[Music]
sisters Lily and Madeline Jurkowitz have
a sound the New York Times called deep
and seamless and relaxed
[Music]
did you have to negotiate this at all in
the beginning or did it just evolve it
just evolved I think Lily's more of an
alto and her voice and I'm more of a
soprano so we've always kind of had that
agreement and that's how we go about it
when you separate what are you here I
think we sound totally different when
we're singing individually I agree but
when we come together it is very similar
something happens what happens I feel
like we like walk into like a third
voice that's like not there you know
what I mean I don't know sounds good
[Music]
the only one who gets
their new album Canterbury Girls is
named after a park in Indianapolis where
they grew up
the sisters first sang professionally
there as teenagers and recorded their
first songs while still in high school
their career got a boost when they
performed with another Indiana native
John Mellencamp but they're not really
sure how it all began
did you just start singing together yeah
there's no answer really I think it's
just because of our mom because she was
so musical and she would sing with us
and she also tried to teach us French
when we were little and we'd sing like
little Nursery Rhymes and she is the
best it did come very naturally and
that's why I think it's been so easy to
progress because we're sisters that can
become a problem too we've been thinking
about that a lot like maybe living
separately would be it's just like
obviously I love doing this with her but
I don't have an individual identity at
this point and doing it with her is the
only thing that defines me that I love
and I would never stop you know if I can
help it but also like you know my
personal life like what's going on there
I don't really know
[Laughter]
Lilly who's now 21 and Madeline who's 23
recently moved together to New York City
why in New York just everything happens
here you wanted to be in the middle of
it all
yeah we wanted it at least try it but
the sisters are on the road again off on
their biggest headlining tour yet you're
pretty much running your own operation
as far as the tour goes definitely we're
driving ourselves we're like - were
managing everything advancing the shows
what's been the best part of this for
you both just meeting people at the
shows people who are so supportive and
so kind our music it touches them and I
had no idea people have these stories
and it really makes you feel like what
you're doing is worthwhile now
performing from their new album
Canterbury girls here are Lilly and
Madeline with just do it